hello and welcome to the Matt Walsh show
thanks for being here remember to
subscribe subscribe subscribe subscribe
on iTunes subscribe on become a premium
member of The Daily wire you can
subscribe that way as well now yesterday
we talked about the barbarous in human
law that was just passed by the New York
State Legislature which makes abortion
legal through every stage of pregnancy
and I explained yesterday how this law
indeed will give women the ability the
power to get an abortion at any time at
any point in their pregnancy up till
birth for any reason now the language of
the law does stipulate that late term
abortions are reserved for women who
have have health concerns or in order to
protect a woman's a mother's health but
that language is is so intentionally
vague that it could apply to any
situation at all as I said you know are
we talking physical health emotional
health psychological health financial
health spiritual health it seems like
any any and all of those could be could
qualify besides abortion is never
actually necessary to protect a woman's
health or her life so when anytime that
qualifier is put into the law that means
that there's something else going on
because that category of abortion
doesn't actually exist so what are they
really doing there obviously they're
just providing a very kind of vague way
for anyone to get an abortion as long as
they so maybe in New York if you're a
woman you want to get an abortion at 30
weeks or 32 weeks or whatever you might
have to couch your reason in terms of
health but that's really yet and I think
that this point is is really crucial I
know that I hammered it yesterday so I'm
not gonna spend a lot of time on it
today but it's important that we stop
and appreciate just how gratuitous and
how unnecessary late term abortion
actually is because the way that the way
that the left talks about the way that
abortion advocates talk about it they're
gonna say that well nobody even gets
late term abortions unless they really
need it so this is this is
they they act like late term abortions
are the most necessary forms of abortion
as in nobody would ever get something
like that unless they absolutely needed
it well that's not true at all of course
all abortion is gratuitous and all
abortion at any stage in any form is
unnecessary and evil but that's
especially the case with a late late
term abortion because here's the reason
why because a woman in the third
trimester if she wanted to or needed to
end her pregnancy she could easily do it
without killing the baby so even with an
abortion if she's getting an abortion in
the in the third trimester she's going
to have to go into labor and delivery
either way if she gets an abortion that
means that the baby is gonna be killed
one or two days before labor and
delivery but you could just cut that
step out which is a dangerous step for
the mother as well by the way you could
just cut that out and deliver the baby
you have a c-section and you're good to
go take the baby out and boom the
pregnancy is over
it could be over in a few minutes that
extra
step of killing the baby is completely
unnecessary it is just murder that's all
there's no reason to do it even in a
situation where a woman legitimately
does have to end her pregnancy because
of some serious health complications
those situations happen there's no
reason though to directly kill the baby
ahead of time you could talk to any any
any real doctor anyone who's or any
nurse who's worked in the labor and
delivery departments of a hospital and
they're they'll talk about you know
they're there they've plenty of
situations where you have these
emergency situations where you got to
get the baby out yeah that does happen
it's rare in any individual case but
overall it happens kind of frequently
but what they'll tell you if they're
being honest is that there's never been
a situation where they had to directly
kill the baby in the process why would
you ever have to do that there may be
plenty of situations where you can't you
can't save the baby it's sadly
tragically despite your best efforts but
you have to directly kill it why so
killing the baby ahead of time is just
it's not not only is it is it evil and
terrible and awful which all abortion is
but it's also it's just as evil and just
as unnecessary and just as egregious as
killing the baby after the birth there's
no difference there's no difference at
all none not even eight not even a
slight difference there is not even a
slight difference between late term
abortion and post birth abortion and I
would challenge any pro-abortion person
to come up with an argument against post
birth abortion that would not also apply
to late term abortion you can't do it or
come up with an argument for late term
abortion that would not also apply to
post birth abortion you can't do it in
fact you really can't come up with an
argument for abortion at any stage that
would not also apply to born infants
let's think about this there
really only four arguments okay there
are four arguments for abortion and
they're all bad arguments but these are
the arguments okay there are there
really no other arguments number one the
number one main argument now is the
woman's autonomy has to be respected
it's what the woman wants to do the baby
is a is a dependent on her and on her
body and on her life and she has a right
to autonomy so she should be able to
express that right enjoy that right
whenever she wants and so if she decides
that you know what I don't want this
baby being dependent on me anymore
then then that's it so that's the
number-one argument autonomy number two
they'll say that the fetus scare quotes
around fetus is is not fully developed
and thus it's not a real person
number three they'll say the fetus is
dependent on his mother and thus not a
person and number four they'll say
sometimes the other argument is well if
if the fetus is not aborted it will just
become an unwanted child and we already
have enough of those to deal with right
so those are the four arguments autonomy
not fully developed thus not a person
dependent thus not a person
overpopulation so those does you go
there you go that's the whole argument
for abortion every single one of those
arguments every single one applies just
as much if not even more to post birth
procedures let's call them so it's a
matter of drawing lines right you got to
decide where to draw the line and the
point that pro-lifers have been making
all along is that we got to draw the
line somewhere the only sensible place
to draw the line is at conception to
draw the line there and say you cannot
kill the babies in the womb once
conception has occurred now you have a
distinct separate living entity which in
the first few moments and days and weeks
after conception might not look like a
fully grown and develop
person but this is a a distinct human
entity a person
and that's the only sensible place to
draw the line that once you have that
human living entity you gotta draw the
line there you can't kill it if you
don't draw the line there then you're
left with there's there there is no
other non arbitrary place to draw it and
if you're not gonna draw it at
conception
there is no reason at all to draw it at
birth nothing really changes it but
that's the thing nothing nothing really
changes at birth other than now the baby
is in a different location it was inside
the mother before now it's outside so
what what is what difference does that
make
there's no reason to draw the line there
there's no reason to draw it in the
moments after birth either there's no
reason to draw it in emphysema see if a
woman decides to keep her post-birth
fetus for a while she's still gonna
discover that this creature is an
enormous strain on her body on her time
on her energy on her life in fact the
infant is much more an imposition on her
autonomy than it was while it was in
inside her body anyone who's had an
infant knows this let me anyone who's at
it when you have an infant in the house
do you feel like an autonomous person no
because you've got this infant you have
to take care of constantly at least
while the baby's inside your body you
don't have to you know the it kind of
the process mostly takes care of itself
right but with with an infant it's like
every waking moment you're taking care
of this baby you're accounting for the
baby you got to wake up in the middle of
the night and feed it and it's you're
changing his diapers and and you're
gonna buy you gotta buy diapers gonna
start buying all these things okay so
now so now there's that financial strain
as well an infant is as much as I said
as much an imposition on a woman's
autonomy and the father's autonomy if
he's involved hopefully he is as the
baby was while it was still inside the
mother's body
so what if a mother decides what if she
comes to the conclusion after say two
months or six months that motherhood
actually is not the best decision for
her what if she decides that you know
it's just it's just it's she doesn't
want to do this she doesn't want to
structure her entire life around this
baby she doesn't want to have to feed
the baby she doesn't want to do these
things it's her life right she's
autonomous what if she gets a major job
offer and and discovers that the the
infant fetus is it makes it difficult
for her to thrive in her new position or
even that with this baby she can't even
accept the position or what if a
thousand other scenarios it's none of
our business anyway right don't want a
post birth abortion don't get one isn't
that the slogan so arguments one two
three and four that I outlined above
they all still hold in this case the
infant fetus interferes with her
autonomy it is not fully developed it is
completely dependent and now that it's
unwanted it has become a member of an
overcrowded category so why shouldn't
she be able to consult with a licensed
physician and make a decision that's
best for her
besides post birth abortions happen all
the time anyway
you can make them illegal but it's not
gonna stop them from how do they still
are going to happen that's just the
reality of the world isn't it better for
there to be a safe and sanitary facility
provided rather than for her after that
for her to have to do it in a back alley
or in a bathtub or something and we
can't draw the line either there you
know so there's no reason to if we're
going to allow abortions of infants in
the womb there's no reason to not allow
them of infants outside of the womb and
there's also no reason to to disallow
abortions of toddlers or or you know
toddler fetuses or adolescent fetuses
because these fetuses also continue to
make demands on a woman's autonomy they
are also wholly dependent on their
parents they're also underdeveloped
physically thus apparently they're not
people
in the strictest sense so what if a
woman discovers that motherhood is the
wrong choice for her when her you know
fetus turns 4 or 6 or 8 or just enters
middle school if we don't draw the line
anywhere in the child's utero
development then why draw it during its
post utero development and on what basis
now am I suggesting that if we accept
abortion that we may as well allow a
woman to abort her fetus at any age
whatsoever no of course I'm not saying
that don't be silly because once the
fetus graduates high school then and it
becomes independent emancipated it's
fully grown it's gotten through puberty
now it is a fully grown entity and so
now I think there is the possibility
that we could consider it a person but
only a possibility because we've already
agreed remember that personhood is based
on a fetuses physical development and on
its ability to care for itself so what
about for example a 23 year old disabled
individual what about an adult on
welfare what about someone who's
homeless what about someone who's sick
and elderly what about those who are
physically developed but but never reach
the intellectual development that could
rightly afford them a claim to
personhood clearly according to abortion
advocates we cannot in good conscience
continue to consider all of them to be
people those are just fetuses too by the
way remember fetus is just Latin for
offspring so that's all that is I said
that's all that may so those are those
are those are also offspring that
according to arguments 1 2 3 & 4 cannot
be considered people and should be
candidates for abortion now it's easy to
say that I'll make
strawman here at our I'm gay I'm
engaging in a slippery slope fallacy
well it is a slippery slope but it's not
a fallacy in fact it's a fallacy to say
that every slippery slope argument is a
fallacy that's not true because
sometimes you are on a slope and
sometimes it is slippery that's just the
fact and the point here that I'm trying
to that I'm trying to illustrate is that
I can take all of the arguments for
abortion all of them and I can take them
fully intact and I can preserving their
integrity if I can call it that and I
can take them over here and I can apply
them to infants to toddlers adolescents
to the disabled to people on welfare to
people who are intellectually stunted to
the elderly and so on I can really apply
all of those arguments to all of those
groups that should trouble you as a
pro-abortion advocate because if you can
look and say wow okay all of my
arguments could easily be used to
justify the holocaust then that means
that either your arguments or bet are
bad or your position is bad or both
that's the whole point of a slippery
slope argument that's why slippery
soulguard slope argument can be a very
legitimate argument because the whole
point is to show you if I can take your
argue whatever argument you made if I
can take it intact and use it to justify
something that we all agree is horrible
then there's something wrong with your
argument or there's something wrong with
your position now in this
there are there are no other arguments
available for abortion so that means
there's just something very wrong with
your position your position is bad it's
terrible it's evil
speaking of evil Governor Andrew Cuomo
in New York has been a huge cheerleader
of this new law even lit the World Trade
Center pink to celebrate it Cuomo is an
alleged Catholic not only Catholic but
he he cites his Catholic faith all the
time to advocate for positions that he
holds which means that the bishops in
New York really have a role to play here
don't they it seems like they should
have something to say and something to
do as well well what have they done the
bishops in New York they did issue a
statement a few days ago about this law
or they express their sadness I'm gonna
read the statement to you the statements
is from the bishops of New York words
are insufficient to describe the
profound sadness we feel at the
contemplated passage of New York State's
new proposed abortion policy we mourn
the unborn infants who will lose their
lives and that the many mothers and
fathers will suffer remorse and
heartbreak as a result the so called
reproductive health Act will expand our
state's already radically permissive law
by empowering more Health Protection to
practitioners to provide abortion and
removing all state restrictions on late
term procedures with an abortion rate
that has already double the national
average New York law is moving in the
wrong direction we were new our pledge
to offer the resources and services of
our charitable agencies and health
services to any woman experiencing an
unplanned pregnancy to support her and
burying her infant raising her family or
placing her child for adoption
there are life-affirming choices
available and we aim to make them more
widely known goes on a little from there
okay that's it's fine right it's a fine
statement I agree with it obviously
you're sad about the law you're mourning
the law it's a bad law fine but this is
not nearly harsh enough it doesn't go
nearly far enough not nearly strong
enough I should mention that Bishop
Edward Scharffen Berger of Albin II he
wrote his own letter condemning the law
and it's it's better than that it's a
lot stronger it's a good letter but
still a lot more needs to be done with
these Catholic politicians who advanced
measures that will result in the deaths
of thousands more babies specifically
you know the thing about the Catholic
Church is that there is a step you can
take a rather dramatic step and that is
you can excommunicate so in every moment
that Andrew Cuomo and Nancy Pelosi and
these other fake Catholic Democrat
politicians every moment that they're
allowed to continue calling themselves
Catholic is a scandal for the church
because they can be publicly
excommunicated and they should be as in
their bishops can stand up and say you
are not a member of the church you are
not Catholic you can call yourself that
but you're not now consider this in in
1962 a group of Catholic segregationists
were excommunicated for publicly
supporting and advancing racist policies
now what Gotham excommunicated was that
they kept doing it even after they were
told by their bishops to stop plus they
were they were making fallacious
theological arguments for these their
evil position they were using their
Catholic faith to justify this evil
which is a great public scandal using
their religion to advance evil and so
that's what got them excommunicated
rightly so in my opinion well that's
exactly what pro-abortion politicians
are doing also it's not just that they
happen to be Catholic which is bad
enough
it's that they use their Catholicism to
advance these sorts of policies
if if these bishops had any had even a
even a little small portion of a spine
they would excommunicate these people
okay one one other quick thing to
mentioned before I get to some of your
emails
the saga over the State of the Union
address is continuing not now Trump says
Trump originally said he was going to
insist that he that he gives the State
of the Union
even though Nancy Pelosi saying you
can't give the State of the Union during
the shutdown Trump said he was going to
give it now Trump sent the tweet this
morning saying that he will wait till
after the shutdown to give the State of
the Union and that is uh look I knew
there was no way that Trump would agree
to not do the State of the Union after
Nancy Pelosi suggested it but I was
really hoping that that Trump would be
the guy to get rid of the State of the
Union I know that I'm not breaking any
new ground here a lot of people complain
about it I just want to register my
complaint as well which will accomplish
nothing I'm sure but I but I'm gonna do
it anyway the State of the Union address
is an absolute I mean it's it's a
disgrace in my opinion the way that it's
handled now the way that State of the
Union addresses were originally given
the way that they should be given is the
president writes a statement talking
about the State of the Union and
releases it and we can all read it right
we all have the internet now and so we
could put it out there we could read it
we can see if ourselves the problem is
all the pageantry that goes into it you
know where you the president walks down
the aisle and everyone stands and claps
then he gets up there and there are
applause lines and then that side
doesn't applaud and that side does it's
this whole it's the theatrics and the
pageantry of it which is just not in
keeping with the American spirit
whatsoever first of all the whole idea
of having of everyone's standing and
applauding as the president makes his
grand entrance down the aisle it's uh
yes I'm the president that's what Kings
do that's that's that's not what
presidents are supposed to do the the
president is supposed to be a public
servant who works for us who we elected
that's what's supposed to separate us
from so many other countries is that we
don't do the whole thing where the guy
walks down the aisle and I was oh let me
reach out and touch his hand that we're
not supposed to do that and the whole
the pageantry of the applauding and the
clap and all it's it's just it's so dumb
and ridiculous and it's also completely
useless in terms of actually finding out
what's going on in the country because
all the State of the Union address has
become is just a campaign speech by the
president that EV that it that becomes
dignified by all the pageantry that
surrounds that we all we all sit and
watch this campaign speech let me ask
you when was the last time in a State of
the Union address you heard a president
talk about the things that his
administration did wrong and things that
he needs to personally improve on when
was the last time you heard a president
say in Stata you know dress it's like
hey you know we tried this thing over
here didn't work out we made this
mistake um if it was a legitimate State
of the Union address and he was actually
just telling you what's going on and
getting you up to speed and it was kind
of objective in that way then then you
would hear that then presidents would do
that but they never do because it's just
it's remarkable it isn't it remarkable
that in every State of the Union address
it turns out that the president is doing
a great job and that although there are
some challenges the country faces we're
headed in the right direction have you
noticed that every single State of the
Union address that's been publicly given
it just so happens that that's the case
I mean it's it's it's it's a it's a
miracle it turns out that every
president is doing a great job and that
the pray the country is always had it in
the right direction according to the
president during the State of the Union
it's a total waste of time and I am just
waiting for the president who will say
you know what I'm done with this I I
don't need the pageantry I don't need
you guys applauding here I'll write this
down it's it's a couple pages long you
can read it boom we're done that's all
it's all we need
finally let's get to some emails if you
want to email the show Matt Walsh show
at gmail.com Matt Walsh show at
gmail.com from Timothy says Matt you
talk so flippantly about so-called late
term abortion he puts that in square
scare quotes you say well just take the
baby out alive and put them up for
adoption you make it sound so easy do
you have any idea how many kids are
waiting around to be adopted in this
country get rid of abortion and you just
create more orphans okay so that's
argument number four that I mentioned
before
there are two problems with the sargan
it's a very common argument this whole
thing about when you talk about the
probe orts will say well what would a
little bro all the kids who already need
to be enough did you have you adopted
any babies two problems here
number one it's it's totally false and
this is this is so often the case with
arguments that pro-abortion people make
where the argument is first of all false
and also irrelevant anyway where even if
it was true it still wouldn't matter so
this argument is both false and
irrelevant let me explain why it's false
it's true that there are a lot of bait
there are a lot of kids there are a lot
of children in in the system now in
foster care up for adoption there are a
lot of there are a lot of kids waiting
to be adopted that is true and it's a
that's true and it's a it's a it's a
very sad thing but it's
not true that there are a bunch of
babies waiting to be adopted in fact if
you had a baby an infant up for adoption
there would be a line around the block
waiting to adopt that baby babies get
adopted like that in this country it is
very easy to get a baby adopted just
talk to any couple that has tried to
adopt a baby an infant and you'll
they'll tell you how long they had to
wait how difficult it was just because
everybody wants to adopt a baby so this
idea that well you know you put the
child up for adoption and he's gonna sit
in foster care and sit in an orphanage
it's just not true
there is a line miles long of people
waiting to adopt babies it's harder
unfortunately sadly to get older
children adopted a child of 6 or 7 years
old and that's that's the really sad
thing you know but it's understandable
from the perspective of of any
individual married couple and they're
looking to adopt and they'd really like
to adopt the baby so they can be there
through its entire life and form that
bond sort of automatically there are a
lot of extra challenges with adopting
older kids which and that's why I have
so much respect for the people who the
heroes who do adopt older children I'm
just talking about the reality of the
situation that's all this is just the
reality that it's very easy to get a
baby adopted that's all
it's irrelevant anyway it's got nothing
to do the issue of adoption and how many
kids are up for adoption that is very
relevant to society it's a very
important thing but in terms of
evaluating the abortion issue it's
irrelevant because the questions
surrounding abortion does a mother have
an inherent right to kill a child just
because it's dependent on her is it true
that you're not a person if you're not
physically developed is it moral to kill
a human being these are those are the
basically the three questions that
surround abortion they have nothing to
do with adoption even if there were a
million babies waiting to be adopted
that would have no bearing on the
answers to those questions so if we
determine that no it's not okay for a
woman to kill her child and that no your
personhood is not dependent on your
physical development and that and that
in that yes it is immoral to
intentionally kill innocent life
well then abortion is wrong again even
if there are 50 million babies waiting
to be adopted it would abortion would
still be wrong in that case so it's it's
an irrelevant point to the abortion
issue this is from
from the other one was from Timothy this
is where I think it's a different person
Matt I'm a huge fan from even before you
join The Daily wire even after you
discredit my email I'll still support
you it's so obvious that our nation is
under attack by outside forces as a
collaborative effort obviously it's not
one evil little man with a mean white
cat but you and Ben Shore do a good job
of joking it off like that for how smart
the two of you are I know you obviously
see it it's very clear that we're being
destroyed from the inside out and that
they are breaking down our morals and
values it's being done through our media
and culture are you guys and the
investigators trying to not cross a
certain line to stay appealing to a
mainstream audience by the way you and
Ben write good books but Michael Knowles
is the best you and Benj to try and
learn a thing or two from him
thank you I agree I remain completely
jealous of Noel's for selling a book
with nothing in it Tim look obviously I
can't speak for Ben but I think but we
both agree that the nation is under
attack that something is happening from
the inside out that our morals and
values are breaking down I think it
seems like what you're taking issue with
is that neither one of us subscribe to
them to most of the conspiracy theories
where the picture is painted of some
kind of homogeneous devious force behind
the scenes pulling the levers and
hatching plans and passing secret notes
to one another pulling the strings you
know coming up with these dastardly
plots and so on I reject that I think
Ben objects that too the reason I don't
subscribe to it is because I just don't
think that's that that is how evil
generally works especially in our
culture it seems to me that many
powerful people powerful forces powerful
institutions are all on the same
ideological page so they don't need to
get together and plot and hatch plans
and conspire in darkened rooms like do
you think that journalists and media
members and the CEOs of these companies
do you think that they all meet in rooms
and agree to try to bring
Trump well no because they are they
already agree it was it was an unspoken
agreement of course they're gonna try to
bring down trouble so that's what
they've been doing they don't there
doesn't need to be a conspiracy they're
all on the same page it's understood it
is an unspoken conspiracy it is a if you
will a a non conspiring conspiracy same
for the media's decision to for instance
ignore the March for Life every year now
that's the kind of thing if you didn't
know any better and you saw how there's
this been this consistent blackout of
the March for life for forty years
even though hundreds of thousands of
people show up in Washington DC which is
media headquarters especially for
political media and yet they're ignored
and if you saw that you would say well
it seems like they this is some sort of
that this is a they apparently have
agreed you know this is some sort of
concerted effort on their part but no
they doesn't need to be a concerted
effort it doesn't need to be a
coordinated effort they all just agree
that of course they're not going to
cover that and most things in our
culture are like that these forces
understand where they want to go where
they're coming from what sort of culture
they want to build and so they move us
in that direction so it's less dramatic
it's less cinematic but it's extremely
effective my other problem with
conspiracy theories by the way is that
is that they always seem to way way
overestimate the intelligence and the
competence of the powers that be take
and I know you probably weren't
referring to this specifically but think
about the moon landing conspiracy not
only is that conspiracy theory
completely baseless and all of the
evidence for it has been debunked a
thousand times but it also would require
a enormous amount of coordination and an
intelligence and competence from a great
many government agencies and individual
bureaucrats not just in America but
across the world and that just if you
know anything about how the government
works and how bureaucrats work and how
bureaucracies work
you would know that is just not possible
finally I want to answer more than that
but I'm gonna cut it off here
so Bridget emails and says I really
enjoy your show have appreciated your
defense of the greatness of the men who
founded our country as well as Columbus
who discovered the land can you please
give me your 30 second elevator speech
about why people are wrong when they say
that the Europeans stole the land and
therefore we as Americans have no right
to it I would love to have a ready
defense when those questions arise so
they as they so often do these days 30
seconds well I don't know if I can
explain anything in 30 seconds I don't
know if you noticed I can't tell
anything in 30 seconds but I'll try to
answer as briefly as possible and I'm
speaking generally here okay there was
some stealing that went on evil acts
were committed it was a rather messy
period of history as all periods of
human history are messy but broad
strokes the idea that we stole this land
and that we're now on stolen land is
absurd it's ridiculous it's not credible
for two main reasons
okay so here's your here's your
ready-made defense number one keep in
mind when we talk about Europeans coming
to the Americas we mean the Americas as
in North Central and South America and
throughout the hemisphere so we're
talking about like
the entire Western Hemisphere we don't
know exactly how many indigenous people
lived through all that space but it was
maybe 20 million some estimates there
are some estimates as low as 10 million
some 20 some 50 let's even take 50
million let's take that let's take a
higher SM so 50 million indigenous
people spread out over something like 16
to 17 million square miles okay keep in
mind there are 300 and there over 300
million people living in just the United
States today so we're talking about at
most maybe 50 million people over the
entire hemisphere so the idea that this
that this relatively small smattering of
disparate isolated disconnected tribes
somehow collectively owned the entire
hemisphere is just absolutely nuts so
what was what human civilization was
supposed to relegate itself to to the
other side of the Atlantic forever
everyone was supposed to stay over there
nobody was allowed to come over here the
advance of human civilization was
supposed to hit an imaginary force field
at the Atlantic and say well guys no
further that's apparently what some
people think because keep in mind they
say that Europeans were invading as soon
as they touch down this is what they'll
say that anywhere the Europeans landed
they were invading anywhere over that 16
million square mile plot of land two
continents apparently according to these
people the Europeans it was hands-off
you weren't allowed to have any part of
either of those continents so if if
settlers were setting up a village in
the wilderness and there was an Indian
tribe 300 miles away what we're being
told is that those settlers were
stealing land from that tribe even
they're in a part of the way that it's
very possible the Indians have never
even been in or even and certainly we're
never planning on doing anything with um
let's just look at one example
specifically the the Cheyenne ok the the
Cheyenne Cheyenne territory in the 18th
century covered about five hundred
thousand square miles do you know how
many Cheyenne existed about thirty five
hundred maybe four thousand you're
telling me that four thousand people
owned five hundred thousand square miles
of land in the middle of the country
nobody else was allowed to go there like
like the hot the entire human race was
supposed to leave five hundred thousand
square miles alone but supposed to cut
out this chunk it's a note no one's
allowed to go there there are a few
people living on that land and they're
all bunched up you know in in tribes and
so of that five hundred thousand square
miles I'd say about four hundred and
ninety thousand square miles of it
completely unoccupied but no one's
allowed to go there it just doesn't make
any sense now how do you see that
doesn't justify the slaughter of Native
Americans it doesn't justify actual
atrocities that were committed but the
idea that natives owned the entire
Western Hemisphere is obviously
ludicrous I mean how can anyone suggest
that second point we talk about Native
Americans like they were some sort of
homogenous unified group but they
weren't and they didn't see themselves
that way and
so to say that we stolen from Native
Americans that sentence doesn't actually
make any sense because that there they
were not one big group altogether right
these were these were isolated tribes
that ward with each other and killed
each other and enslaved each other and
stole land from each other they stole
land from each other all the time so if
the Europeans did steal land most likely
they were stealing land that already
been stolen about 50 times before that
now that doesn't justify it again but
back in those days everywhere in the
world this is how it worked this is how
human civilizations spread not just
European civilization not just white
civilization civilization of any type
this is how it spread including among
the Native Americans and indigenous
people this helps but it's spread by it
was understood that if you had land you
had the defendant if you can't defend
your land it's gonna get taken from you
most likely 3,000 people can't defend
500,000 square miles it's gonna get
taken from you that doesn't make it
right that's just how it worked back in
those days among everybody that was the
that was just how humanity spread those
were the rules of the road back then
that everybody understood and everybody
abided by so yeah you could say well
that doesn't justify with knit it would
what the Europeans fine but it it also
means that you can't just hang this
thing around their necks if you're gonna
blame them for stealing land you have to
blame everybody including Native
Americans for stealing land and then
once you start doing that you realize
that okay well this whole blame game
doesn't make any sense anymore because
now we're just castigating all of human
civilization up until about a hundred
years ago but if you're gonna be honest
and consistent that's what you have to
do think about when the Spanish came to
Central America and they overthrew the
Aztecs okay the Aztecs were one of the
most barbaric civilizations to ever
exist in the face of the earth they they
they committed human sacrifices tens of
thousands a year where they swear they
slaves they stole people from
neighboring lands and tribes and they
brought them up the temple steps and
they ripped their hearts out and then
cut their limbs off and consumed the
limbs and then rolled the bodies down
the temple stuff this is what they did
to tens of thousands of people this was
a barbaric civilization
anyway the Spanish come they band
together with other neighboring tribes
who all hated the Aztecs for good reason
you know when you're when you're when
your neighbor next door has just been
had his heart ripped out by the Aztecs
you might kind of have be sort of salty
towards them so they banded together
they overthrew the Aztecs and this is
used as an example of oh the the Spanish
stole the Aztec land where do you think
the Aztecs got it they got that land by
stealing it
not only stealing it but they would
steal it and then slaughter you and rip
your heart out after they took your land
and take slaves so again you you could
say well yeah they still stole it okay
but the Aztecs did too so you can't you
can't mourn them there are also thieves
that stole in so we got to trace all the
way back who was the original person
that owned that land it's like it's like
if I stole your car and then someone
stole your car from me now we could
blame that person for being a thief but
we can't say that I'm the victim
I stole the car not only did I steal the
car but I killed you when I stole it
except in this case we're talking about
a car that's been stolen by like a
hundred different people and no one even
remembers who the first person was so
that's how I would respond to to that
argument now what's in 30 seconds but
that's the answer anyway all right I got
to leave it there thanks for watching
everybody thanks for listening Godspeed